véritables scènes invraisemblables
incroyable aujourd'hui en europe au
cours d'un match de football
l'horreur en direct à la télévision
c'était le 29 mai 1985 il y a tout juste
35 ans au stade du heysel à bruxelles
lors de la finale de coupe d'europe de
football des hooligans du club de
liverpool viennent de charger des
supporters de la juventus
les italiens se retrouvent acculés dans
leur couple les supporteurs essaie de se
jeter des tribunes ils tomberont cinq
mètres plus bas
souvent les gens vont briser le bilan
est lourd 39 morts en majorité des
italiens mais aussi des belges et des
français
plus de 450 personnes sont également
blessées dans la catastrophe
si tant de morts tant de morts à
l'origine du drame un stade trop vétuste
mais aussi trop de spectateurs debout et
une présence policière quasi inexistante
pour ceux supporteurs italiens
les forces de l'ordre belges n'ont tout
simplement pas assurer leur sécurité
la police belge n'a pas fait son travail
ils ont laissé faire les anglais qui ont
démonté les palissades pour nous est
acquis un coup de barre de fer face aux
critiques
les autorités tentent de se défendre je
précise que la police serait la piste
uniquement dans l'enceinte du stade est
question gradins les blocs et meinau
situé de l'autre côté donc d'où les
incidents se sont produits alors à qui
la faute
pour le ministre de l'intérieur belge
nous responsables et ailleurs et a un
nom le hooliganisme
selon lui des sanctions doivent être
prises à l'encontre des clubs anglais
tant que les conditions de déroulement
correct de semblables manifestations ne
seront pas établi de manière catégorique
par l'union européenne de football ou
par les responsables des clubs anglais
d'interdire toute compétition ou
interviendrait des clubs britanniques
sur le territoire de la belgique trois
semaines après le drame
lui est pas interdit aux clubs anglais
de participer aux compétitions
européennes pendant cinq ans à celui de
liverpool pendant six ans
en 1989 le procès du sl rend son verdict
épilogue demain à bruxelles du fameux
procès d'huez elle un responsable de la
fédération belge de football un site un
capitaine de gendarmerie sont condamnés
du côté des hooligans anglais 14 sont
condamnés à trois ans de prison dont 18
mois avec sursis
trop peu pour une des victimes
aujourd'hui on est x trop pied on est
invalide ou en a subi des souffrances et
où on a perdu son emploi et ou pas voilà
un franc symbolique
voilà résultat des peine alourdie en
appel un an plus tard pour onze des
quatorze lits gagnent en 1994 le stade
du heysel et rénover plus moderne et
plus sécurisé il sera rebaptisé stade du
roi baudouin en 1995
[Musique]